The teaser trailer for It: Chapter 2 was recently
released, and everyone’s starting to get
excited for the sequel.
Here are a few theories I have about Chapter
2.
This video is sponsored by Raid: Shadow Legends.
Theory Number 1: The Fate of Henry Bowers.
As a child, Henry Bowers is the most feared
bully in town, terrorizing the Losers Club
with his gang of thugs and his switchblade.
His mental stability deteriorates towards
the end of the summer, when he kills his father
and goes after the Loser’s Club to try to
kill them as well.
As an adult, Henry plays a significant part
in the book.
He’s broken out of a mental asylum by It
to seek revenge.
But in It: Chapter 1, Henry is bested by Mike,
who knocks him into the well in the basement
of 29 Neibolt, which looks to go on forever.
This has led many to believe that the second
film will be taking a different approach.
But before I talk about my thoughts on how
Henry might have survived, let me show you
how you can survive in a dark RPG fantasy
world with Raid: Shadow Legends.
Ahhh!!
Dinner is served!
Now I used to play these types of games on
the computer when I was a kid, and I was honestly
pretty amazed that a mobile game could have
just as good graphics, and be just as immersive
as a PC experience.
Now I haven’t upgraded my phone in a while,
and as you can see, this runs completely smooth
and it doesn't have a negative impact on the
graphics either.
But aside from that this game really takes
the story seriously, which is important to
me.
The boss fights are these huge epic battles,
there are hundreds of Champions in this game
for you to collect to collect and customize,
AND on top of that Raid’s Special Launch
Tournament is happening right now.
So if you download Raid ONLY through my link
in the description, you’ll get 50,000 in-game
Silver immediately, but the coolest part is
you’ll also be automatically entered into
their Special Launch Tournament, where you
can compete with ME and other players for
crazy in-game prizes AND physical prize packs.
We’re talking figurines, power banks, T-shirts,
and more showing up at your house, so use
the link in the description to download Raid
today.
So how did Henry Bowers survive the fall in
the wellhouse?
We’ve already seen that It has the power
to transfigure parts of the house, so I think
it stands to reason that it could have created
some kind of net, or something to catch Henry.
Henry had already proven himself a worthy
servant by killing off his father at the request
of Pennywise and in a deleted scene and killing
his two friends, Victor and Belch.
If we take that to be canon, then it might
not really work for either of them to be the
form that It uses to break Henry out of the
asylum, so maybe Henry never actually left
Derry.
I think it’s kind of a creepy idea to consider
that It kept Henry down in the sewers all
those years, just waiting to unleash his minion
again 27 years later.
Theory Number 2: We discover the origin of
It.
In 1990, the first adaptation of It was released
in the form of a 2-part TV mini-series.
Understandably, with the novel coming in at
over 1100 pages, some of those scenes had
to be left out, one of which was the smoke-hole
scene, where the members of the Loser’s
Club attempt to carry out an ancient Native
American ritual to help them decide what they
should do about their Pennywise problem.
The ritual involves them starting a campfire
in their underground fort and breathing in
the smoke until they have a vision telling
them what to do.
If that sounds familiar, you may have already
read the book, or maybe you just hung out
with the wrong kids in high school, I don’t
really know.
But when they carry out the ritual, everyone
jumps out for air except Richie and Mike,
and they see their tiny clubhouse expand,
and then the smoke clears and they find themselves
in the middle of the Barrens, but the landscape
is different and they are surrounded by animals
that haven’t lived in Maine for thousands
of years.
Now I’m not going to spoil anything, but
they basically see the arrival of It.
This scene takes place when they’re kids,
and it’s obviously not in Chapter 1, but
just because we didn’t see it in the movie
doesn’t mean it didn’t happen.
We’ve already seen in the trailer that there
will be flashbacks to when they were all children,
and the majority of the adult portion of the
novel is their forgotten childhood memories
coming back to them.
So I think we could either see a smoke-hole
scene as a flashback in Chapter 2, or another
scene that explains Pennywise’s origins.
Based on the trailer, it already looks like
there’s going to be some backstory on Pennywise’s
human form, Bob Gray, which is the name Pennywise
uses to introduce itself to several characters
in the book such as Georgie, Eddie and Beverly.
My third theory pertains to the final form
of It.
Now obviously there’s no way I can do this
one without going into spoilers, so if you
haven’t seen the mini-series or read the
book, it’s a quick enough read isn’t it?
You can just breeze through that puppy in…
uh… an hour or two?
So when it comes to the 1990 adaptation, the
most common complaint by far is the final
spider form, it’s probably the least scary
part making everything feel a bit anticlimactic.
And it’s just following the book, but in
the book King is able to explain that it’s
not really a spider, and that that’s just
the closest thing our tiny human brains can
interpret It as.
But the response to the mini-series spider
has led some to believe that the filmmakers
behind It: Chapter 2 are going to take it
in a different direction.
We have seen them setup a possible showdown
between It and Bill, which is known as The
Ritual of Chud in the book, where Bill is
launched outside of his physical body into
this thing called The Macroverse, where he
basically has to defeat It with his mind,
with the guidance of another celestial being
known as The Turtle, who is also teased at
and referenced in Chapter One.
“It’s a turtle!”
However, unlike the smoke hole scene, it's
not like that’s something that could have
happened but it just wasn’t shown in the
first movie.
We see the final battle and that doesn’t
happen.
But what does happen is Pennywise temporarily
transforms into a half-arachnid creature while
cycling among forms.
I have to think this is a little tease that
the second movie will stay true to the idea
of It’s final form appearing as a spider
to the Losers.
However, I don’t think that necessarily
means that it’s going to be anticlimactic
again, I just think they have to make a cooler
looking arachnid than the one from 1990.
Maybe instead of a giant spider, it’s more
of a half clown, half spider alien hybrid.
I always thought it was strange that we’re
haunted by a clown for the whole story, but
then at the end it’s just a spider all the
sudden, so I think incorporating the clown
into the spider form be a more fitting conclusion.
Let me know what your own theories are in
the comments and click the video on the left
to check out everything you might have missed
in the trailer for It: Chapter 2.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications, check out Raid: Shadow Legends
in the description, and I’ll see you in
the next one.
Assuming we both survive.